hey guys Greg knuckles here with string
theory calm back with the 12th I believe
installment of our semi daily Q&A series
today's question is why for most people
our deadlifts harder to recover from
than squats are obviously that's not
true for all people at all time but most
people report that if they're doing the
same volume of both squats and deadlifts
the deadlifts take quite a bit longer to
recover from and are going to negatively
impact training for more subsequent days
after the deadlift workout then a squat
workout with a similar amount of volume
would so I will say on the outside of
this video that I'm purely stating my
opinions and the views that I've come up
with via my own experience and some
mechanistic reasoning to the best of my
knowledge this is not a topic that's
actually been researched so there's not
a concrete answer but here's what I
think so I think that there are likely
three things in play here one is that it
causes more fatigue of the spinal
erectors and so you very possibly get
just a decrease in central motor
impulses because your central nervous
system in terms of priorities one of the
very most important things it tries to
do is make sure that your spine is safe
and well supported not compromised so it
would make sense that when you're dead
lifting really hard maybe with a little
bit of spinal flexion you cause a lot of
fatigue and those final erectors it
makes some sense that there would be a
decrease in just central motor impulses
until your spinal erectors were you know
nice and recovered again and your spine
felt safe and supported as it should be
so that's that's the first thing that I
think might be going on the second would
be your hands getting really really
beaten up if you want to have some
nightmare
you'll just Google human homunculus that
is your brains picture of your body
based on sensory nerve density and for
most people all around their face and
their genitals on their hands and their
feet have a Ton Ton Ton of sensory
nerves which are constantly sending
feedback to and from the spinal cord to
to to and from the brain and a lot of
athletes they report that you know when
they're training really hard in their
feet get beat up their performance just
absolutely goes to [ __ ] and I really
think a similar thing may be going on
with the deadlift as well your hands
getting beat up your grip feeling really
fatigued you know anything you're doing
where you have to hold on to something
especially with a knurled bar for the
next few days you just get an unpleasant
sensation of holding on to that bar
which again perhaps via interacting just
with some reflex pathways via the spinal
cord maybe again a similar thing
decrease in central motor output that
very well could be something that makes
deadlifts take a little bit longer to
recover from just my own personal
experience with this when I'm dead
lifting with a fairly high volume if I
do most of my work with straps I find it
much much easier to recover from my
hands arm is banged up the next day and
my you know my training the next day is
probably going to suffer a little bit
but two days later I'm good to go again
three days later definitely good to go
again
whereas if I had a similar amount of
training volume without straps exact
same demand to my spinal erectors glutes
hamstrings everything else but my hands
are also really fatigued and beat up
from that session that's typically going
to then negatively impact my training
for the next three or four days so I
think that that's probably something in
play as well and then the last thing and
this this would probably be the biggest
one for newer lifters is just most
people when they pick up the bar for the
first time they're just much
bed lifters than they are squatters
deadlifts are much more similar to
things you've been doing your whole life
picking up something off of the floor
whereas you know maybe you've been
squatting your whole life to poop or
something I don't know but you haven't
been doing that with a really heavy load
on your shoulders or really any load on
your shoulders so that's just not a
pattern just not a bracing pattern that
comes nearly as naturally for most
people and so with new lifters you see
you tend to see a really really big gap
between their deadlift and their squat
that closes over time as they get more
experienced squatting so I think with
with newer lifters most of them you know
right off the bat they're more
technically skilled with the deadlift
they can lift more weight relative to
the maximum that they would be capable
of lifting if they were very very
skilled at the lift
you know if the maximum possible is a
hundred percent deadlift skill a new
lifter may come into it with seventy
percent or something and then add maybe
some shitty form on top of that with
some lumbar flexion and you know you
just have a perfect storm for something
that's going to be difficult to recover
from versus squats squats don't tend to
be nearly as tolerant of spinal flexion
and also if you can have a hundred
percent skill in the squat most new
people first time you put the bar on
their back there maybe a twenty thirty
percent so just purely the output that
they can really put into the squat and
deadlift is going to be much much higher
for the deadlift which is going to make
that just more inherently fatiguing so
again this is just my opinion these
these are the reasons that seem the most
plausible to me
just more spinal erectors fatigue lumbar
erectors specifically and your central
nervous system just kind of taking
everything down a notch until your spine
feels safe and secure and support it
again to your hands getting beat up and
all of that just negative feedback every
time you have to grip something that may
affect central motor impulse as well and
then also just motivation to go hard
like if your hands hurt like [ __ ]
just uh you know maybe makes you think
twice about going quite as hard about
maybe more deadlifts maybe no binge
that's pressing into your hands really
hard rows pull ups pull down something
like that and then the last thing is
most people who are especially fairly
new to lifting maybe been at it for two
or three years or less are just they
tend to just naturally be more skilled
bed lifters and squatters when they
first pick up the bar which will then
make the deadlift inherently more
fatiguing because their output when
they're training would be closer to the
maximum output that those muscles would
be capable of so that is the video if
you liked it please like and subscribe
and if you have a question you want
answered ask it in the comments below
and if it is my favorite I will address
it in that next video alright until then
hope you have a good day hope your
training is going well and I will see
you next time